let's start things off with obviously
you and i are both extremely passionate
about the synthesis of science and
spirituality
metaphysics understanding the nature of
reality the nature of consciousness
we're taking at it from such similar and
also slightly different perspectives
which is
this is going to be an epic back and
forth on that i loved
the learning about the living mirror
theory of consciousness
and especially the understanding
from from what i understood from your
video i liked
the fact that you went all the way back
to what you could say is
a biogenesis and just the i
the idea that you you can't divide
uh the cell from the cell's
understanding of its environment those
two things are coupled together if you
don't divide those things you understand
the unity of everything
but that's this general idea is that the
the living system
needs to understand its world will you
take us through that that process and
elaborate a bit
yeah definitely and so the way you said
it is perfect like the fact that
in order to exist as a living system in
order to have form and to like to have
some kind of structure that's relatively
separate from the world around you need
to be
you need to attempt to know what's going
on around you otherwise you're just
going to get demolished by all the
forces in the world
that you know that demolish all the
things that aren't alive right
um and this this is not currently
the kind of way that most people think
about consciousness in the kind of
scientific and philosophical mainstream
we have this like hangover from uh
well it's the kind of whole lineage of
western thought where we we kind of
assume that single-celled organisms are
just little mechanisms they're like
little clockwork
things that just kind of do their thing
and it's a very kind of um
it's a view that really takes away any
of the kind of or what a like vast
universe of complexity
like a single cell is you know so you
you'll hear scientists on the one hand
almost dismiss plants and single cells
as these
boring little mechanisms and yeah on the
other hand like life is the kind of one
of the greatest mysteries in the world
and we're talking about
life when we talk about a bacteria or a
single cell right um
so so yeah my the the simple way of
saying the theory is exactly as you said
that
it's really as simple as every living
system
uh which is a system that actively keeps
itself together
actively perpetuates its form it has to
attempt to know
what's going on in its environment it
needs to know of itself in its
environment
um and this is just another way of
saying consciousness it kind of
it constructs beliefs about what's going
on like in existence in
in kind of a qualitative picture of the
world um
and this is we're talking now at a kind
of conceptual level but
which is how it first came to me but
then it turns out if you if you dig into
the kind of hard
like physics and like statistical
physics and maths behind the
thermodynamics of life
it's there the same stuff is there you
can unpack it at that level as well
and it was it was that when i saw that i
was like okay like this is
this i this isn't just hand waving you
know saying oh maybe
maybe that's how where consciousness is
i'm i'm utterly convinced now that this
is the
um as you say abiogenesis the moment the
life pops into existence that is the
moment the consciousness pops into
existence
because then you have a system that can
be aware before then
everything is just truly one system
where everything is dissolving into
everything else and you can't really
point to an object
and say is that conscious because you
know we can label a rock in the ocean as
a rock in the ocean
but really there's no boundary there
it's just being dissolved and
everything's
just kind of you know um melting into
each other in this kind of
in this kind of single thing we call
physical reality and so you can't
even say as a rock conscious but you can
point to the pattern of life
and say is that conscious and so there's
also
i think that's something i've not spoken
about in public but i think it's quite a
powerful
way of thinking about this life forms
with life forms you can even you can ask
if they're conscious
with everything else you can't even
really ask if it's conscious
in the ultimate nature of
this infinite consciousness this god the
source this implicant
whatever the that we want to use as that
as the main metaphysical uh truth
that within that ocean is that infinite
is a whirlpool and we've
been using this whirlpool analogy that
there's this whirlpool which is the
abiogenesis
for the whole planet and then there are
these whirlpools for all eight billion
human creatures as well and that the
whirlpool
itself is the formation
of the the the coupling
of the uh the this the single celled
organism at the first time to its
environment the coupling of that
there needs to be a ledger mechanism in
a sense
like i i really like using a ledger or
um idea because the cell itself
has a ledger when we've had a
dr chow tong on the show and he is
extremely
obsessed with these these
these the mathematics of understanding
cells
because they do have a cycle they have a
a schedule for mitosis they they they
must
know they have a protein buildup that
signals to them
at which point it's safe to divide um
given their memory and their history and
so there
without a doubt the same idea applies
to us do i have enough
resources right now for me to procreate
if the answer is
no i'm i'm not going to procreate there
will not be
mating and uh and further
the recursive function of making more
humans and so
the this this idea that your life
is is inextricably connected to the
to your environment and now did you
choose the word um mirror because
of how it's all in a sense we talk about
this so much in
in spiritual world where if it is just
this one consciousness that is having
the
the symphonic experience through all
eight billion
artists and that there's that we're all
in a sense
mirrors of the same source and so is
that the idea that both the mirror
of the individual and their environment
like that
there's that coupling together of the of
the
ledger of the person in their
environment but also the mirroring of
all eight billion
of us of that source
yeah so so i would say that the um the
word mirror
is referring to a kind of property of
the living system but the consciousness
itself is like a reflection
so if you want to understand a
reflection
you know the analogy would be for
neuroscientists trying to understand
consciousness by just looking at the
brain in isolation
it would be like studying the surface of
a mirror and trying to figure out what
all these patterns are
like you can't if you refuse to think
about photons and you refuse to think
about how they reflect off of other
surfaces
that then get reflected in the mirror
then you're not going to understand what
what a reflection is it's it's something
that can only be understood as a process
arising in this in this very zoomed out
picture
where you're considering the photons
you're considering the surface
properties of the mirror
um and so similarly with with living
systems when you zoom out and you see
living systems as as you say a kind of
whirlpool
as a pattern in reality that perpetuates
itself
a feature of those patterns is that
there's this kind of informational
reflection
of the structure of the world around the
system inside it
and this is kind of what consciousness
is i would say
um and i think it's to go back to um
you were you were saying the kind of the
source or the kind of you know
i might call it the ground of being
right if we get into this kind of
these metaphysical questions um part of
the reason people have found it hard to
think about the place of consciousness
in nature
is kind of articulated by something
called the hard problem of consciousness
which
can be thought of in a few different
ways but one way of thinking about it is
as a metaphysical problem that you've
got the kind of hard matter that makes
up the world
and then there's a kind of substance
that exists and then you've got mind
which is kind of another substance and
somehow you've got a map between the two
uh if you look
at you know prior to this kind of um
this scientific narrative that the world
is made of little material building
blocks most kind of
spiritual traditions have this idea that
the ground of being is something
utterly beyond our concepts you can call
it mata you can call it consciousness
you can call it whatever you want
but it's it's utterly it's the ground
like the territory is so much greater
and vaster than the map
these little words we say are nothing in
the face of the kind of the source of
existence